there's a couple really strange things
related to gout that I want to discuss
why is it that 70 of people with gout
have high blood pressure
I mean that's that's weird especially
since uric acid which most people know
that gout is a problem of uric acid
building up in your big toe is
considered a powerful antioxidant
if it's an antioxidant then why is it
associated with high blood pressure and
why is it associated with so much pain
in your right big toe so that's what
we're going to sort out today and I have
some interesting conclusions and ideas
if you have gout you're going to be very
glad you watch this video you know it's
not just high levels of uric acid in
your blood that's causing gout because
they found there's no correlation
between levels of uric acid in the blood
and gout attacks but they do know the
pain of gout is this uric acid Crystal
formation creating a lot of inflammation
so what is going on here well what they
do now your kidney is not able to get
rid of this uric acid effectively it
tends to retain uric acid and then
somehow it leaks into the joint of your
big toe and it forms crystals the main
medication for gout is called alopurinol
and what that does is it inhibits the
formation of uric acid there's an enzyme
called xanthine oxidase which helps you
make uric acid so this medication blocks
that enzyme thereby lessening them out
of uric acid now the problem with this
medication is it creates all some side
effects and some pretty major side
effects so a lot of people don't like to
take it so they're searching out for
alternative methods to help their gout
but I think once you understand some of
these things I'm going to talk about and
sort out some of these Mysteries and
paradoxes
you'll have a solution a common natural
remedy for gout is celery seed another
common remedy would be tart cherry and
both of these can actually inhibit that
enzyme and that's probably why they do
help a certain amount of people but
there's a couple other points of this
problem that I want to bring up number
one why is there such a high correlation
between gout and high blood pressure and
cardiovascular problems that's kind of a
mystery that relates to this Paradox
this information that's kind of
conflicting because uric acid is
considered an antioxidant
as well as a pro-oxidant now that's the
conflicting information so how can it
get rid of inflammation but cause
inflammation if it's such a powerful
antioxidant in your blood then why is it
associated with
heart problems okay why is it one of the
strong predictors of heart problems in
fact it's also linked with insulin
resistance and even liver fat but how
can this be if it's supposed to be an
antioxidant so let me just kind of go
through a couple interesting points
about this
number one and this is what I found out
uric acid inhibits nitric oxide nitric
oxide is what a lot of people are trying
to increase to lower blood pressure to
help their hearts to protect the inside
of the arteries and it's considered a
powerful antioxidant it's a potent
vasodilator okay so it just it relaxes
the blood vessels so it's really good
for high blood pressure other people try
to increase it for other reasons like
erectile dysfunction because if it's a
potent vasodilator it can help with
erections and so people take Viagra for
example which increases nitric oxide or
they might take a natural form of that
called L-Arginine which increases nitric
oxide so nitric oxide is a powerful
antioxidant but uric acid inhibits this
nitric oxide I mean if you even think
about what happens to a gout patient
with their big toe
you're getting a tremendous amount of
inflammation you're getting a lot of
free radical damage you're getting a lot
of oxidative stress right and if you
don't have this nitric oxide to counter
that you're going to have a problem the
other point I'll bring up and this is
interesting nitric oxide can help
regulate
that enzyme that makes uric acid so it
can help decrease or inhibit this
xanthine oxidase but on the flip side if
you have uric acid that's going to
inhibit nitric oxide so what's going on
I really think what's really going on at
a deeper level is there must be some
type of genetic weakness that sets
someone up for this problem with the
inability to eliminate uric acid and
maybe even the inability to produce
enough nitric oxide or absorb enough
nitric oxide
but that being said um I'm going to
cover some other points that relate to
this coming back to this celery this
phytonutrient that can help increase
nitric oxide is not really present in
large quantities in the stock but it is
present in the celery seed extract in
larger amounts as well as the celery
leaves okay those little things that you
kind of cut off and don't eat right
those are the things you need to eat if
you have gout it's the leaves of the
celery now you can also get this
phytonutrient from artichokes artichokes
is a good source also sage in Thyme and
you can also get it in a lot of other
leafy greens as well but I'm just
pointing this out that there's even
people that have claimed to get rid of
their gout by taking artichoke another
common remedy would be to actually lower
your sodium chloride apparently salt
inhibits nitric oxide especially if
someone is salt sensitive okay when I
read that line okay in this article a
little thing popped up in my mind
because anytime someone mentioned salt
sensitivity what they're really
describing is the potassium deficiency
because you really no longer become salt
sensitive if you get enough potassium
and so now the question is what is the
relationship between potassium and
nitric oxide well apparently potassium
increases nitric oxide in a potent way
and this could also be the reason why
quite a few anecdotal reports indicate
that taking potassium can help reduce
gout and so you have this restriction of
sodium that helps gout and this taking
potassium that helps go personally I
think it's the ratios if you get the
ratios just right I think you're going
to be in good shape but if you have gout
and you're taking a lot of sodium that
could potentially be a problem I always
recommend having sufficient amount of
salt especially sea salt but for some
people with gout maybe it's not the best
idea maybe you restrict your salt but
you start really increasing your
potassium to the level where maybe your
gal can go away now the other thing
related to potassium is that diuretics
okay deplete potassium
they also get rid of sodium
and diuretics are linked with decreasing
nitric oxide as well as uric acid and
potassium is alkaline and so we also
know that if you alkalize your urine
you'll have less gout attacks another
interesting connection
omega-3 fatty acids also increase nitric
oxide okay and we know that omega-3 is
an anti-inflammatory and so the real big
idea with nitric oxide is this it's an
antioxidant okay and if you have
inflammation in your big toe you need
antioxidants and nitric oxide could just
be what you've been missing and there's
also some additional data about uric
acid I want to bring up now is it an
antioxidant is it a pro-oxidant well I
think it's both because there's some
data that when it gets into the tissues
intracellular it becomes a pro-oxidant
which would make a lot of sense because
if this uric acid gets into your
arteries or let's say it gets into the
joint then it starts creating
inflammation that's why we need nitric
oxide because it's not only an
anti-inflammatory
it's an antioxidant as well there's
another term I want to introduce you to
and it's called an inflammasome A
protein that is within the immune system
that you're born with and apparently
this inflamasome triggers a Cascade of
inflammatory things that happen a gout
attack and nitric oxide is a potent
suppressor
of this inflammasome what are some other
things that can trigger a gout attack
well you have fructose and when people
have fructose oh my gosh they just have
a worsened attack and it just so happens
that fructose and sugar decrease nitric
oxide all this is very interesting but
what can we do as action steps number
one increase your potassium okay both
from foods and supplement form if you
get into electrolyte powder you can do
that or if you get it in pills you're
only going to find it in like 99
milligram tablets so you might need to
take several of them several times
through the day or if you're doing it in
an electrolyte powder you can take
several spoops through the day just
spread it out that'll give you enough
potassium also eat foods high in
potassium at the same time I would
recommend if you have a bad gout case to
reduce your sodium just don't add a lot
of sodium I think that's going to help
you because remember sodium or salt
inactivates this nitric oxide the next
thing is to eat foods that can Spike
nitric oxide like the leaves in the
celery okay the tart cherry
artichokes leafy greens number four
avoid fructose and sugar and the last
tip and this is another important thing
which I think can help you you want to
support the kidney with something that
can help eliminate the stearic acid as a
product I used to use in practice called
Arena food that's a good thing to order
and take if you have gout now on the
note of potassium
very important mineral okay if you
haven't seen my video on potassium I'm
going to put it up right here check it
out